INTERVIEWER: Ninjas were a
class of covert operatives
that are believed to have
existed in Japan from the 15th
to 17th century, and
possibly even earlier.
While they no longer
officially exist,
the mystique of these
ancient assassins
has been popularized
over the centuries.
And recently, the town
of Aichi, in Japan,
posted a job listing seeking
to hire full-time ninjas.
SATOSHI ADACHI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
CHRIS O'NEILL: I have no
anxiety to do acrobatic tricks
and audition that way.
But the interview section was
going to be all in Japanese,
so I was so nervous to get up
and speak-- It was a challenge.
I don't know if I'm
much of a performer,
but I love ninja culture,
I love ninja history,
I love Japanese history-- I
just wanted to be a ninja!
SATOSHI ADACHI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
INTERVIEWER: As
professional ninjas,
they travel around the
country and abroad,
showcasing warrior skills
at live performances.
EMI YAMADA: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
SATOSHI ADACHI:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
EMI YAMADA: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
CHRIS O'NEILL: I really
like talking to people
about coming to Aichi
and coming to Nagoya.
I'm passionate about this
place, it's beautiful.
For me, this is real Japan.
It's got so much
history, so much culture.
I fell in love with
this place, and I really
want to share real Japan
with everybody else.
But I'm so excited to be
the first [JAPANESE] ninja.
I think it shows people that
no matter what anybody says,
anything is possible.
When I was a kid,
I said, I wanted
to be a ninja--
people laughed at me.
But I worked hard, I
waited for that chance,
and I finally got it.
It's a big responsibility
and I'm going to do my best.
INTERVIEWER: Be
sure to check out
this next episode about
another unusual career path,
as told by the
supermodel of hands.
ELLEN SIROT: I wear
gloves quite often,
especially when I'm
outside, to protect
my hands from the elements and
from things that can happen.
But I take really
good care of them,
and you'll see why I'm a
hand model-- because I have
flawless skin, and nice long
nails, and very graceful hands,
and that's really
become my signature.
INTERVIEWER: And
please don't forget
to subscribe to
Seeker Stories so you
can see new videos every week.